hey this is presh showwalker
a rectangle has dimensions of 15
centimeters and six centimeters
construct the diagonal of the rectangle
and construct the following horizontal
and vertical lengths
suppose this upper triangle has an area
of 16 square centimeters and this lower
triangle has an area of four square
centimeters
then shade this rectangle the question
is what is the area of the rectangle
this was an actual question in a 2005
exam in Singapore the psle and it was
question 13.
while it seems like a simple question
it's actually impossible to solve
can you figure out why
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try and when you're ready
keep watching to learn how to solve this
problem
[Music]
so first let me go over the intended
solution
consider this right triangle over here
it's exactly congruent to the right
triangle that's above it because we have
a rectangle that's divided by its
diagonal which will switch the rectangle
into two equal triangles so this
triangle has an area that's equal to 16
square centimeters
let's say the rectangle has an area
that's equal to R
so now let's focus on half of the big
rectangle what is the area of this
triangle
it will be equal to 16 plus 4 plus r but
it will also be equal to half the area
of the entire rectangle so it will also
be equal to 15 times 60 divided by 2.
so let's just focus on this equation
we have 20 plus r is equal to 45 and
that means R is equal to 25 square
centimeters and that's the answer
or is it
let's take a look at the problem again I
actually approach it in a different way
let's say the rectangle has Dimensions
that are X and Y
let's calculate some of the other
dimensions in this figure
this length will be X then here we have
6 minus y this length will be 15 minus X
and this height will be equal to y
so let's calculate the areas of these
triangles in terms of X and Y
in this upper triangle we will have X
multiplied by 6 minus y all over 2 is
equal to 16. we can multiply both sides
of the equation by 2 to get X multiplied
by 6 minus y is equal to 32.
the other triangle has dimensions of Y
and 15 minus X so we have y multiplied
by 50 minus X all over 2 is equal to 4.
multiplying both sides of the equation
by 2 we get y multiplied by 15 minus X
is equal to eight
now there's one more thing to notice
these two angles are equal to each other
because they're vertical angles
then these two angles will be equal to
each other because they're alternate
interior angles because opposite sides
of the rectangle are parallel to each
other so these two triangles are similar
to each other
what does that mean
that means their lengths will be in the
same ratio so x divided by 6 minus y is
equal to 15 minus x divided by y
we can cross multiply to get X
multiplied by Y is equal to 6 minus y
multiplied by 15 minus X
so now let's just focus on the equations
let's multiply the two equations on the
right hand side
we get X Y multiplied by 6 minus X
multiplied by 15 minus X is equal to 32
times 8. but we know that 6 minus y
multiplied by 50 minus X is equal to X Y
so we can substitute in X Y
we now have the square of X Y is equal
to 256 taking just the positive value we
get X Y is equal to 16 square
centimeters
but X Y was exactly what the area of the
rectangle is supposed to be
so we've come up with a different answer
is it 16 square centimeters or 25 square
centimeters so obviously something is
wrong with the given information
so what exactly is going on let's try to
salvage the problem
this upper triangle is similar to the
entire half of the rectangle so its
ratio of sides must be the same as the
ratio sides of half the rectangle
so we have x divided by 6 minus y is
equal to 15 over 6.
now suppose this upper triangle has an
area of 16 square centimeters
so we have X multiplied by 6 minus y is
equal to 32.
from the first equation we can solve for
6 minus y and then we substitute it into
the second equation we can then solve
for the positive value of x to get that
X is equal to 4 root 5. we can then
solve for y from there we can figure out
the area of the lower triangle and that
will be approximately 7.33 square
centimeters which then means the area of
this rectangle will approximately be
21.67 so that would be the way to solve
the problem
to its credit the examination board did
admit its mistake and did give all
students full marks
but this problem teaches a larger point
a good student can figure out a problem
from the given information but a great
student can see whether the given
information makes any sense
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on YouTube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve The World's problems one video at
a time
foreign